all right never been a fan of the
Resident Evil movies but I will go into
this movie and I will be fair I will be
fair don't worry
Resident Evil retribution so the
Resident Evil movies are loosely based
on the Resident Evil games zombies have
taken over the world and it's up to
Alice played by milla jovovich or Yahveh
vich or however you want to say your
name to stop it or at least deal with it
for another movie or so in the beginning
of this movie where it showed the end of
the last movie and it showed everybody
on that boat just get wiped out just in
the beginning of this movie I was like I
hate it when movies do that and
after that we see things happen and
you're like is there a point to all this
it's edited really strangely and I get
it I get how they want to show you what
umbrellas doing and whatnot but it's
like Alice wakes up in a house and she's
like oh I'm in a house and I have a deaf
daughter and no life is good then
zombies come in and raid the place then
she's captured in this interrogation
room that looks like a it's a really
tall room with the walls are lit really
white you know and the ground is one big
umbrella symbol when she gets out of
this interrogation chamber this drawer
opens up that conveniently has her gear
and now we go on another adventure yeah
like I said I'll be fair and I'm being
fair but I got some to say I am not
completely convinced that this Resident
Evil movie has a point whatsoever I mean
first of all Albert Wesker comes on a TV
and he's like hello I was still talking
like Agent Smith but news flash in the
last Resident Evil movie he died like
died died like really died and even if
he didn't die she thinks he died when
she sees him she's just like Wesker not
holy how are you living what are
you like a cockroach you stamp one out
another one grows in your place what is
this this is Magic it's black magic this
is no none of that she just
kind of buys it she's like oh yeah I
guess he's alive because he's Albert
Wesker bad guys just lived through
we are led to believe that a couple of
two-by-fours landing on super shredder
killed him but we're supposed to by the
fact that Albert Wesker lived through
the last movie no sirs no mam's this
movie is just a bunch of conveniences
wrapped up in just a bunch of scenes of
people fighting zombies because hey you
we have to fight zombies in 3d so we can
charge overpriced 3d tickets to get
money to entertain people but entertain
people like the whole premises they're
in this underground base of umbrella so
they're the zone
these zones are like five city blocks of
certain cities like all five blocks on
Moscow five blocks of Tokyo five blocks
of New York so they go through these
zones and every time they're in a zone
they have to get into a boss flight from
a video game and live through it then
they go to the next one all right let's
see what happens in level two all right
this happens in level two all right
let's see what happens in level three
are there anyone ups and the cast was
just absurd you look at the cast and
you're like these are like the porn star
versions of the Resident Evil characters
like Leon Kennedy's this generic looking
dude with the chiseled John a middle
part Barry Burton's this really cut dude
he's the guy who plays a dick and
everything and now he's Barry Burton he
has a beard he's really ripped that's
right you're watching porn actors with
no sex whatsoever it is what it is
that's what it is I know why my mind
went there but that's just what I
thought when I saw these generic looking
people
the noise happens you know firefights
and zombies and I get why it just
irritates me because we don't know what
they're gonna do about it
we know the fact that they have to get
out of these situations or at least
survive until the next shitty situation
we don't know what they're fighting for
you know that alright umbrellas bad and
they probably have to take it out at
some point but there's no focus there's
no moment where it's like alright this
is what we're going to do to end it all
we don't know that Frodo and Sam are
going to Mount Doom to drop the ring and
to end it all so far is just a bunch of
people trying to live through shitty
situations zombies and people with guns
for fighting to exist and that's just
not enough for me not by movie 5 or
whatever this is and apparently Paul WS
Anderson doesn't even know what kind of
zombies he has in his movie
are they ravenous mindless animalistic
zombies that just eat people yes they
are are they intelligent enough zombies
to march in a militant formation while
shooting machine guns and rocket
launchers at the good guys while driving
jeeps and rocking the 50 Cal yes they
are so they're mindless ghouls and
they're smart military zombies what's
when the movie became almost comedy to
me and you have a lot of that 3d crap
where things are flying by the screen
there was one where someone threw
something and then it showed them
fighting down there and that thing came
at the screen from like a long way it
just the no one dodged it or anything it
just flew at the screen to fly at the
screen to show off the 3d Resident Evil
retribution was just loud noise it was
like arguing with your girlfriend you
know you see it's just loud noise that
doesn't make sense and it's just not
logical example this is one of the
examples there's this big monster it
kills everything that comes across kills
them eats them annihilates except for
the little girl in the movie it gets the
little girl and cocoons her up for no
reason whatsoever never explained why
she was cocooned up it never explained
why it didn't kill and eat her I could
just see Paul WS Anderson going look I'm
a big aliens fan I love the scene where
the alien took Newton Ripley had to go
get Newt so we're going to do that in
this movie in order for that to happen
the big monster can't kill an eater but
hey it's all right little just cocoon er
up and then Alice just goes up there
smokes the thing she's hit in the head
gets her and goes off she was cocoon for
like two minutes the entire scene in
Scenario is completely pointless you
just see someone who wanted to put that
in the movie and had to eliminate all
logic and reason given the monsters and
characters he had before him to do it
I'll say this Resident Evil retribution
is every bit as good every bit is
illogical and every bit as loud as
transformers revenge of the Fallen
you know that god-awful transformers
movie that I do not hide the fact that I
hate it's like that it's the same kind
of entertainment loud popcorn
entertainment that does not make any
sense
it isn't constructed well it has no form
or structure just happens for a
couple hours now if you like
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen fine
cool and you might like this movie if
you don't like Transformers Revenge of
the Fallen you probably won't like
Resident Evil retribution and no I'm not
hard on this movie because I like the
Resident Evil games I'm hard on this
movie because I like good movies this
movie is not one of them Resident Evil
retribution gets the prestigious award
of dog the movie itself in its
construction and execution feels like a
really bad video game and I know that
the Resident Evil movies are based off
the Resident Evil games a little bit but
your movie based off of a video game
isn't supposed to feel like a bad video
game it's not supposed to feel like more
of a video game the video game is based
off of your your favorite zombie movie
show graphic novel entertainment outlet
at all what's your favorite zombie story
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you